well as they say everything is bigger in
texas and that certainly goes for
political controversies too
the state as you know has become a
hotbed for lightning rod issues like
abortion illegal immigration and voting
rights
but there's one man
sitting on the sidelines who believes
that he is the one
who can save the state from the evil
republican in the governor's mansion a
man confident enough to shake off not
one but two embarrassing political
defeats a man so unpopular
he made kamala harris
look likable
that man is robert francis o'rourke but
you may know him as beethoven
remember folks he was just born
to be in it
beto must have the memory of a goldfish
because he had to drop out of the
democrat primary race after polling at
less than one percent in iowa
but we didn't forget
we remember his trip to the dentist's
office
we remember his airport push-ups
and we remember how he waved his arms
around like those those weird inflatable
men you find outside car washes
he ran a campaign for the ages and i for
one am shocked that he didn't fare
better
but as they say if at first you don't
succeed try try again
and on behalf of the media i love to
speak for all the media in america and
every republican in texas i say run beto
please run
join me now to discuss former white
house deputy chief of staff karl rove
carl what say you is this beeto's moment
2022 governor's mansion texas
every moment is robert francis
o'rourke's moment every single moment
the news broke this morning and
immediately what happened well we got
the fundraising appeal
you know breaking news
helped turn texas red excuse me blue
then later on the afternoon 50 000
signatures urgently needed for robert
francis o'rourke send your signature in
now sign up now that you'll be
supporting him and then finally at the
end of the day we got a hint of what
we're likely to see from the campaign
this is not from robert francis o'rourke
it's not from the democratic governors
association but michelle beckley who's
running for congress a member of the
state house representatives she has set
for the robert francis o'rourke
theme of the campaign
governor greg abbott's time in office
has been characterized by misogyny
homophobia corruption and racism and
that's just since we've launched our
campaign for congress we need someone to
take him on in the next election and
robert francis o'rourke has stepped
forward he will enact common sense gun
reform fight for the freedom to vote
stand against corruption and protect the
reproductive rights of the people in
texas
abbott's reign of terror must end we've
had enough and the man to replace him is
then she said that abbott's reign of
terror sort of like rose pierre
you know
yeah and then robert francis o'rourke is
gonna save us from all of that you know
carl i don't i sense that you may not be
serious uh in every way but i i i didn't
ever see george w bush
come on stage on a skateboard i mean i
you he never did that beto did i mean
that's that is something to contend with
we encouraged governor bush and then
president bush to do that at every
opportunity and he refused our
entreaties to do so but robert francis
o'rourke
understood how important it is to
demonstrate that in order to be a leader
you've got to be able to skateboard
real quick though in all seriousness
in 2022 does he really think he has a
chance in texas sure he does he's talked
himself into it but but
governor abbott is not going to do what
happened in the last campaign than that
was he was ignored this guy is far out
on the left wing he has said
extraordinarily
bizarre things that place him far out on
the on the progressive left of the
democratic party and governor abbott
who's been a strong effective leader for
texas is not going to let him get away
with that stuff the guy who said he was
coming for everybody's ar-15 the guy who
says he's for unlimited right to
abortion all of that stuff is going to
be fair game in this election he is
going for the hat trick of losses karl
rove thank you very much appreciate it
good to see your time won't be the charm
won't be the charm hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else